concerns over the flu the first day of
winter is still a few weeks away but the
start of flu season appears to be here
with between 1.7 and 2 and a half
million flu related illnesses already
reported according to the Centers for
Disease Control and Prevention forecasts
suggest that flu activity will continue
to rise there's a 40 percent chance it
will now peak in December which the CDC
notes would be considered early compared
to previous years we are joined at the
table by CBS News medical contributor
dr. David agus doctor good morning do we
know why it seems to be hitting early
this year and what that means for the
rest of flu season we don't know why flu
season happens when or where but it's
happening early it's clear it's
happening in these southern United
States
you know New Orleans particularly hit
and you know 1.7 and 2.5 million people
that's up so number early is it too late
to get the vaccine right now for people
that haven't that's a leading question
that's what I meant really question
about it yeah and we don't know whether
this is gonna be an early peak say it'll
peak in December yeah or whether there's
gonna be drawn out like last year you
know on an average year 125 to 200
people a day die of the flu so this is
preventable most of these deaths with
the vaccine even though the vaccine
hasn't been great the last couple of
years this year the early strain that
we're seeing is Type B called Victoria
and that classically happens in February
March that sure is happening early you
know we don't really know any of these
trends and predictions what's gonna
happen but what we do know is it's here
what we do know is it's early and what
we do know is we have a preventive shot
right I got it I promise
yeah no and because you have a happen to
have one yes DJ you do I got in the
greenroom right after the show making
everybody sick Dana you have all these
strains out there so I'm wondering does
just one vaccine sort of like nip it in
the bud the answer is no we don't have a
universal flu vaccine the past couple
years we haven't been great we science
hasn't been great at predicting it the
hope is this year it's a little bit
better but either way when you get it
even if the strain wasn't there you're
immune response is going to be less with
me true God could be a sick right so get
that flu that series promise promise dr.
David agus thank you